1987:
El Parlamento Vasco me encarga
que cree un Centro
de Investigación por la Paz
y Tratamiento de Conflictos
en Guernika.
Le pongo de nombre Guernika Gogoratuz
que en euskera significa
recordando a través del corazón Guernika.
Y lo dirijo 14 años
de logros y fracasos.
Y en los que me voy gradualmente
dando cuenta de que la paz es débil,
es un desastre de debilidad.
¿Y cómo? Bien sencillo:
Todos queremos la paz,
pero queremos otras cosas
más que a la paz.
Y esas cosas hacen que nos enfrentemos
unos con otros.
Y de ahí resulta que nos armemos,
que amenacemos con guerras,
y que las hagamos.
Y las estamos haciendo.
Las estamos haciendo sin darnos cuenta.
¿Cuántos de nosotros sabemos
cuántas guerras estamos haciendo hoy?
7...10...
¿Cuántas hacemos oficialmente?
¿Cuántas hacemos inoficialmente?
¿Cuánto matamos con drones,
cada día, cada minuto?
No se sabe, pero...
lo que sabemos es que el ejército
más destructor de la Tierra,
mucho más que el resto juntos,
tiene como comandante supremo a alguien
que ostenta el Premio Nobel de la Paz.
Pasamos a un día aciago:
11 de marzo de 2004.
El día en que revientan los trenes
por atentados terroristas.
El día en que se rompen sueños.
Se rompen vidas.
Día de inmenso dolor.
En Madrid, encuentro a los afectados
y al grupo que se ha juntado
para apoyar a los afectados.
Y compartimos inquietudes
y también el afán de cómo hacer
que la voluntad de paz
tenga más fuerza.
Esa inquietud la trasladamos
a Medialab Prado
y comparte ese afán,
y ahí generamos un grupo muy variopinto,
de más de 50 [personas]
que pone en marcha
en el año 2011 un proyecto.
Y el proyecto consiste
en coleccionar y hacer públicos
relatos con hebras de paz viva.
Eso no lo entiende nadie...
(Risas)
¿Y eso qué es?
Como hebras de paz viva o hebras,
entendemos actos, acciones generosas,
desinteresadas
de ayuda a alguien en grave peligro
o en una situación de abuso intolerable
por verse como parte de un grupo enemigo
o de un grupo extraño.
Además, acciones insumisas
que rompen la disciplina
y la sumisión que se impone
desde el grupo en que uno está.
Acciones que a primera vista
parecen extrañas, raras,
sobrenaturales, de héroes,
de gente excepcional, insensatas.
Pero que según las vamos buscando
y encontrando
vemos que son hechas por gente
que se entiende como común y corriente,
que es gente normal que no entiende
que ha hecho ninguna heroicidad,
sino que simplemente ha hecho
lo que le tocaba hacer.
Y nos damos cuenta de que la razón
de que no se encuentren
es que no se buscan.
Estamos recogiendo esos relatos.
Los recogemos porque hay algunos, muchos,
ya publicados, chequeados,
relatos seguros.
Pero la mayoría de los relatos
no los recogemos nosotros
sino que los recogen chavales,
alumnos de institutos,
entre 11 y 17 años,
que con ayuda de sus profesores
y con la complicidad de sus familias,
charlan sobre los mayores
de su familia o de su confianza.
Así, el abuelo de un alumno
le regala un relato.
Su padre, al comienzo de la guerra
se encuentra en la zona republicana
pero su familia está en la zona de Franco
y quiere cruzar el frente,
para unirse con su familia, desarmado.
Y al intentar hacerlo, se encuentra
con un miliciano de guardia, armado,
precisamente con la orden
de impedir que lo haga.
Se queda rígido,
se miran uno a otro
no hablan para nada
y el miliciano en vez de
apuntarle con el fusil,
le hace un gesto tranquilizador
con la mano, de que pase,
pasa, y cambia su vida.
Ahora aterrizamos en Berlín
para mostrar como vamos adquiriendo
la capacidad de ver esas hebras
en la vida diaria a nuestro alrededor.
Hace unos meses en Berlín,
a las 11 de la noche
en una estación de metro.
Entra un grupo de muchachos, media docena,
bebidos, gritones,
como con pinta de skinheads,
en un vagón y se encuentran que hay ahí
una señora mayor, sentada,
y a unos metros de ella un muchacho negro.
Enseguida se encienden
y empiezan a provocarle
con gestos y muecas y gritos.
Algo va a pasar.
Pero lo que pasa es,
no lo que pensamos,
sino que la buena mujer
se levanta de su asiento
y se va poquito a poquito
y se sienta al lado del muchacho negro
y se pone a hablar con él
como si tal cosa.
Y eso descoloca al grupo.
Bajan la voz y se bajan
en la próxima estación.
No ha pasado nada, pero de una forma sutil
esa mujer ha librado al muchacho negro
de una bestial paliza.
Todos los pueblos tenemos
pasados traumáticos.
Entonces recogemos relatos
de Guatemala bajo Ríos Montt,
de Argentina con la Junta,
del Holocausto,
de Palestina de muchos tiempos,
de la antigua Yugoslavia,
y de Siria, tenemos relatos de Siria de hoy,
memoria del presente.
Cogemos estos relatos, los chequeamos
y corregimos algún fallo
que puede que tengan a veces.
Luego los pasamos a un formato
adecuado para que se presenten en público.
Entonces peregrinamos con ellos
desde la intimidad de las familias
que callaban esos relatos
hasta que se hagan públicos.
Y vamos a hacerlos públicos.
Aquí. Ahora.
Pero en octubre, a mediados de octubre
en Wroclaw, en Polonia,
en diciembre-enero en Donosti,
y en nuestra página web.
¿Y qué tienen que ver estos relatos
con la voluntad de paz?
La voluntad de paz
se alimenta de la memoria.
Pero no de cualquier memoria,
sino de lo que los expertos llaman
la memoria colectiva,
que es una memoria
que arrastra a las voluntades.
Y esa memoria tiene tres rasgos:
Uno, es selectiva;
dos, es cerrada;
tres, es amarga y negra.
Selectiva
porque del pasado
que vivieron nuestros mayores
recoge los trozos que
hablan bien del propio grupo
que aparece como:
humano, víctima, inocente, heroico.
En contraste con todos los otros grupos
que aparecen como culpables,
causantes del trauma vivido,
traidores, cobardes, alimañas,
faltos de humanidad, inhumanos.
Son memorias que rechazan
los relatos del otro,
y blindan los propios.
Y que además ven el pasado
con las gafas de la justicia penal.
Y la justicia penal entiende de delito,
de crimen, de dolor, de arrepentimiento,
de castigo, de culpa...
y poco más.
El resto son atenuantes.
Hay una memoria que educa para la paz
otra que impulsa la guerra
y a veces ni se sabe
qué memoria está promoviendo qué,
pero tienen muchísima fuerza.
Fijaos, por ejemplo: qué es lo que
origina la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
La memoria colectiva que construye
la Alemania nazi
de la derrota humillante que sufrió
en la Primera Guerra Mundial.
Sin la memoria de esa derrota
no se desencadena
la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Y la memoria que alimenta la paz
es más débil
que la que alimenta la guerra.
Porque la que alimenta la guerra
lo hace a tope.
Pero la que alimenta la paz
lo hace a medias,
porque la paz es más
de lo que nosotros creemos.
No es la paz como definen los expertos,
la paz negativa,
que es la paz del no
a la guerra y a la violencia,
es decir que no
señalar un pasado y decir nunca más.
Así está toda Europa
llena de monumentos a los caídos,
les enfants de la Patrie,
de cementerios,
de antiguos campos de concentración
gritando todos nunca más.
Fuera de ese pasado.
Pero la paz no solo es
la paz del nunca más,
sino que la paz es mucho más.
Hay lo que los expertos llaman
la paz positiva
y nosotros llamamos la paz viva,
que es la memoria de nuestra necesidad
y nuestros actos de convivencia,
[eso] es la paz viva.
Estamos inmersos
en esa paz de convivencia.
La vida no nos la damos nosotros
sino que nos la dan otras vidas.
Y nuestra vida se alberga sus
primeros meses antes del nacimiento
en el cuerpo de una mujer.
Ya eso es convivencia.
Y la convivencia estamos
toda nuestra vida diaria
sabemos de esta convivencia
y contamos con ella.
Anteayer he venido en tren desde Donosti
he cogido el metro con la maleta.
Y según iba subiendo
las escaleras de piedra
2, 3, 4 personas que iban bajando
han venido con una sonrisa así, alegre,
a ayudarme a subir la maleta,
imaginaos si me llego a caer.
(Risas)
Eso es tan evidente
que nos olvidamos de ello.
Es demasiado simple para conceptualizarlo.
Lo que ocurre es que al construir
las memorias colectivas,
como ya he dicho, se queda descartado.
Esas memorias colectivas
tan poderosas
y tan controladoras de la voluntad
nos presentan esa construcción
del pasado amargo y oscuro.
Si entonces metemos ahí relatos
con hebras de paz viva,
metemos una lucecita
que hace que aparezca en ese pasado
un paisaje alegre, ameno, atrayente,
un pasado que no solo denuncia el pasado
sino que anuncia el futuro.
La paz negativa
atiende a nuestra necesidad
de seguridad y de justicia
y es el alimento base de la memoria,
el alimento amargo y oscuro.
Las pequeñas dosis de hebras de paz viva
son el afrodisíaco que añadimos
a ese alimento
y así sale una mezcla maravillosa.
Y la fuerza que
la voluntad de paz necesita
para pasar de un mundo en guerra
a un mundo que está
arrinconando la guerra.
Muchos de vosotros,
que me veis mejor a mí que yo a vosotros
ya veo que estáis empezando a pensar:
eso ha pasado en mi familia,
eso ha pasado con mi tía,
o con este cuñado así raro
que no conocemos mucho de su vida.
(Risas)
Entonces estáis empezando a encontrar
en el pasado, tesoros escondidos.
Pues igual me pasa a mí.
Cuando yo tenía cuatro años
un taxista republicano
echó una hebra de paz viva a mi padre
a unos kilómetros de aquí
y le salvó la vida.
Es un recuerdo, una joya
que quedó enterrada
en la memoria familiar, no se comentaba.
Pero 48 años después,
muere mi padre.
Y el día que mi padre muere
hay una llamada de teléfono.
Y dice: "soy la viuda del taxista
que salvó la vida de su padre,
que ha muerto en Rusia,
que tuvo que emigrar".
Ella ha desenterrado ese tesoro escondido
y me lo ha regalado,
y yo ahora lo estoy haciendo público.
Estoy rompiendo una ley
muy callada de mi familia
de que estas cosas no se comentan.
Y las estoy comentando,
y me lo van a agradecer.
Así que ahora os puedo pasar la pelota
porque vosotros también tenéis
vuestra tierra ignota, que es el pasado
en la que hay tesoros escondidos.
Pero paso la pelota de un campo de juego
al otro campo de juego,
y si tenéis relatos así,
si queréis, mandádnoslos.
Nuestra dirección es muy fácil.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)